with up today we are unboxing whip step
basic joy cones
no these are not face it gray at least I
hope not I'm sure a lot of you guys are
familiar with color where they do all
kinds of cool custom color skins for
pretty much everything from drones to
iPhones to Joy cons and no this isn't
sponsored i prettier this the second
that I saw it online all of you guys
sent me this if you don't know what I'm
talking about inside here are joy cons
that are vintage and yes themed relief
that's what I'm hoping
the excitement is oh man
I'm waiting so longer these this is
incredible I have never purchased
anything from color wear before so this
is my first color wear product and the
cool thing is they also included the joy
con strap that are also the same color
gray they did such an incredible job
[Music]
here's a real challenge taking me oh
please sometimes is so difficult to get
these this drops off of here that is
absolutely insane the real test is
what's it going to look like on then
it's I know switch all together oh my
gosh looks perfect
[Music]
well I guess now it's time for next
level montage
[Music]
Hey
Oh God
[Music]
drama stop to enjoy times I never did
show you guys my platoon themed
controllers wait no this isn't right
there's a green where's the green oh my
god this isn't even the right color ah
some people are selling them watermelons
there's all kinds of funny meme
especially this one it was probably my
favorite I've never watched the show The
Fairly OddParents they do look pretty
awesome though other than the vintage
NES themes are gone this is probably my
favorite customization the hot pink and
the neon yellow why wait that's bad guys
thank you so much for watching and sorry
this is such a short video but I really
really wanted to show you these joy con
I've been looking forward to these for
such a long time and I'm so impressed
with how good it look let me know what's
which games you guys are most looking
forward to I'm so excited for Mario
Odyssey I even tweeted something the
other day as a diver Mario Odyssey yeah
I just want to go to sleep and wake up
and it'd be time for Mario Odyssey I've
also been playing overcooks which is
such a fun game I played it a bunch on
xbox and now I've been playing it on a
Nintendo switch I've been trying to get
my sister into it she's like but no it
feels like actual work playing this game
well that being said I got so good at
playing by myself to spend trying to
play with another person who was so
frustrating I was like Jenna please just
cut the meat no I'll have to go get the
bread started that's it I'll see you
guys later bye
god is good I'm so proud
[Music]